if you have recently been treated for a
heart attack a condition caused by a
blockage of blood flow to your heart
muscle this video will help you
understand the condition and its
treatment your heart is a muscular organ
that pumps blood containing the oxygen
and nutrients your body needs the main
pumping chamber of your heart is the
left ventricle when your left ventricle
contracts it sends oxygen-rich blood to
your body through a large artery called
the aorta connected to your aorta our
small arteries called coronary arteries
blood flows from your aorta through the
coronary arteries to supply your heart
muscle with oxygen and nutrients
during your heart attack blood flow
through one of your coronary arteries
may have been severely reduced or
completely blocked your reduced blood
flow may have been caused by a buildup
of a fatty substance called plaque in
your coronary arteries
if this plaque became disrupted a blood
clot might form and severely worsen the
narrowing or lead to a sudden complete
blockage stopping blood flow down the
artery
a blockage in your coronary arteries
prevented the oxygen and nutrients in
your blood from reaching the part of
your heart supplied by the artery as a
result heart muscle in that area started
to die
damage to part of your heart muscle is
called a heart attack it's also known as
a myocardial infarction or MI
your heart doctor may have recommended a
procedure to help open the blockage and
improve blood flow to the damaged area
the procedure you had may have been a
coronary angioplasty during a coronary
angioplasty a balloon tipped catheter
inflates inside your blocked coronary
artery to open it
the procedure may have involved placing
a stent to help prop the artery open
this is usually a thin metal mesh that
acts as a scaffold
or you may have had a coronary artery
bypass graft or cabbage
cabbage is a surgical procedure in which
the blocked areas of the coronary
arteries are bypassed with veins or
other arteries from the body
before you left the hospital your
healthcare provider most likely
prescribed several medications
your medication may include the
following oral antiplatelet therapy
helps prevent platelets from sticking
together and forming new blood clots
you may have also received drugs called
beta blockers that help lower your heart
rate and blood pressure
drugs such as angiotensin converting
enzyme or ACE inhibitors angiotensin
receptor blockers or AR B's and calcium
channel blockers also work to lower your
blood pressure if needed and you may
have been prescribed statins along with
a low-fat diet to lower your cholesterol
these drugs work by reducing the amount
of cholesterol made in your liver
it is important to stay on your
medications as your physician prescribed
even if you are feeling better do not go
off your medication unless the
healthcare professional that prescribed
them tells you to